in america we buy a lot of [ __ ]
like a lot of [ __ ]
and you said that some of the
happiest people you've ever seen in your
day have just been the poorest people
that didn't have a lot of stuff going on
their life and i think that you know
what i've seen is that americans
consume a lot of stuff i'm not saying
i'm a minimalist but i i definitely
gravitate towards being a minimalist not
needing the fancy stuff
to fulfill your life like it's a it's a
it's actually a scientifically proven to
be a sugar high oh i want to get this i
want to get this and three days later
you know you're super excited to get a
new pair of shoes or a new bag or a new
whatever and three days later
scientifically your um
emotions or
morphines that's why i mean it's like we
look at the like bushido right musashi
said we look at the externals to
to allow us to feel something internally
right and wealth is one of them right uh
materialistic items is another one look
that's an american thing exactly okay
that's an american thing we're
credit cards we're not going to change
that okay well this we're not i don't
know if we're going to change the entire
culture but this is where you have to
look inside
yourself and look in the mirror and say
do i really need this is buying more
stuff
really what i'm looking for in life i
get it people need the basics people
need milk people need you know gas in
this case
all the consumerism but also the
shortages it's because the gas prices
are going through the roof yeah the
shortage on truck workers and the
mandates yeah so i i feel like that's
shorting that's closing down the supply
chain as well these are two different
issues here what should your church say
okay so let's just say what you're
saying is save that money fine well i'm
just saying that there's a flip side to
the supply chain stuff it's that how
much stuff do you need we're talking
about they're cancelling christmas but
so you're not getting 20 christmas
presents
that's a question to say how rich is
good how rich is rich like so so
if you if you live in america the reason
why you love america is because the
person has the freedom to choose okay
america was founded on four different
things freedom to choose freedom to
freedom to buy freedom to sell freedom
to fail freedom to try buy sell try fail
it's up to you go for it's capitalism do
what you got to do you want to buy it
buy it you don't want to buy it don't
buy it it's totally up to you
this is not a
uh uh
philosophical conversation here about
this this is about why the hell do we
have the shortages one is saying we're
buying too much the other is saying oh
it's because
100 ships are sitting out there we can't
get it up people don't want to come in
here and work and take that stuff off
ten thousand containers that you're
talking about the biggest one they got
23 these ships are the biggest ships you
know you got jen sackey uh uh
who comes out yesterday saying when
asked about biden's supply chain crisis
saki cracks a joke at the expense of
americans this is a post-millennial
story she says it was a cl it was clear
march of 2020 when covert hit that the
supply chain across the world had been
disrupted even as a sort of work to
fight back against covet proceeded
people it was crystal clear that the
that things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things so why did
the tragedy of the treadmills that's
delayed
she talks about him joking about it
during the pandemic many gyms were close
et cetera et cetera so
you know this is about this christmas
people are not going to get stuff on
time and they're preparing everybody
don't expect your gifts to show up on
time why is this happening america is
not going to change their habits
overnight that takes a generation or two
to do but this concern here you got a
capitalistic society who's accustomed to
getting products being delivered on time
now they're not yeah this isn't
philosophy this is management you know
philosophically you want to talk about
minimalism it's a different conversation
i agree yeah like this is you know the
this is just america this is a global
supply issue it's not like this is
immune to america yeah only in america
it's crazy it's almost like the entire
world i know it's crazy it's almost like
you're right nothing and be happy right
because the entire world's been dealing
with a pandemic
but yeah poorly too
so listen the the la la in particular
there's the regulations are what are
shutting down the la right now it's it's
it's government that's causing a
six-month backlog it's not the pandemic
it's the government response to the
pandemic it's also the lack of workers
we discuss yeah which is which is due to
the government response to the pandemic
you know this is it's it's it's very
very very clear there's not a backlog in
jacksonville right now one of the
biggest ports on the east coast is there
a six-month backlog of the is the supply
chain broken and in the you're saying
this is on gavin newsom
it's on gavin newsom okay it's on bill
de blasio it's on andrew cuomo it's on
it's on people that aren't in control
how are they how's new york affecting
l.a
de blasio
this is a literal nationwide logistics
problem that we just said it was just
fun jacksonville is the problem
jacksonville is fine
you can you can look at where the
backlog is there's a backlog in new york
harbor there's a backlog in elizabeth
there's a backlog the the la backlog is
astonite it's like six months behind
right now it's actually cheaper for a
lot of these ships to redirect from the
pacific go through the freaking panama
canal and then come to the east coast
they will on they will unload quicker
than waiting in port in l.a
you know so
freedom to try freedom to try man listen
this this this is logistics
just this morning there's a guy i had
breakfast with at my uh at my condo man
the guy sells pepperidge farm cookies
it's incredible how much money there is
in cookies man
398 was where the cookies started this
year they're up to 417. he sells them
wholesale he said they'll be five
dollars by the end by the end of the
year i mean that doesn't seem like much
that's a 33 increase in one year just
off of shipping
33 on cookies what what's milk what's
things that need to be refrigerated
cookies can stay on the shelf for two
years what are things that are
perishable i mean it's going to go
through the roof man we've only just
begun to feel the pain
look i i'm with you clearly we need our
stuff in america especially if it's
staple industry but we talked about it
takes generations to fix
well i'll flip it on you there's
somebody named marie kondo you know who
that is
who basically said
you know goes to people's houses and
says does this spark joy to you
and if not get out get rid of it sure no
matter what's going on with supply chain
and macroeconomics and tariffs or
whatever at the end of the day this
comes down to how many [ __ ] cookies
do you actually need okay how much extra
stuff do you need i got i get staples
i'll put you on friday i'll put you on
front street then why do you live in
boca raton for three times the amount of
money it would cost you to go live out
in coral springs
right like you can go we can go west in
the swamps and live for five hundred
dollars if it's about efficiency yeah
how can we don't live out there you can
have a like where i live yeah that's
your choice but that would be cool okay
to do it that would be seen as excessive
that would i don't think that success
how dare you place to live
it's it's excessive as compared to
buying a single wide out in the swamps
right like i mean if everything is about
efficiency if everything if materials
yeah but if the world crumbled
and i had to go live in a smaller place
i didn't have any money i'd still be
happy
like i get it like supply like i'm not
like oh my god i have to go and move
into a smaller unit buddy i lived in a
little
shack in dallas
just to be a minimalist well you loved
it not really
but i did it because i wanted to be a
part of valuetainment and that's what i
was willing to do to go through the
struggle in this case i mean not that
big of a deal but that's what i was
willing to do
but
a part of me i understand our supply
chain i get it but cry me a river if
your cookies are a dollar more bro so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]